with garbage like sour yeah what that is  for me it's coriander he's guys he's  gonna say we have to talk business  community mere talk about business  what can I bring for you on this  glorious afternoon well Hector here's  the game plan you know bring us two  Absolut martinis you know how I like him  straight up and then precisely seven and  1/2 minutes after that you gotta bring  us two more then two more after that  every five minutes until one of us  passes out what strategy sir I'm good  with water for now though thank you it's  his first day on Wall Street  give him time  I feel like a curse top not a curse top  no curses  it's just Afghanistan that's all way I  see it we got three options one let him  go hike up probably be found in less  than an hour till we tie him up  I got roll the dice they'll probably be  eaten by wolves or freeze to death three  we terminate the compromise we cannot do  that